huge news actually the AP now projecting
that Donald Trump has won the state of
Pennsylvania that is the race frankly
there is no path forward for Hillary
Clinton if this we've just seen that
Pennsylvania has been called by AP I
think for me this is one of the most
stunning results of the night we had
seen her up comfortably five to six
points when we go through the data and
we look at where he sort of held up it
was in some of the suburban counties
huge showing in the western part of the
state you can see the faces right now
we're looking at a live shot that looks
like Clinton headquarters that's
actually Donald Trump headquarters I see
all the red hats there that will be the
moment they have been waiting for I
can't even imagine the cheers of me and
we cheers will be going on and we should
emphasize again this is a moment that
many there tonight certainly will not
have expected it's a it's a it's a
development that will confound the
pundits the polling universe and sort of
that we didn't really see as much as we
saw it Briggs that people thought they
weren't going to be surprised again it
looks in fact we almost know that we are
looking at very much the same night
tonight Megan Murphy I've been watching
you go over the data from Pennsylvania
where were the deficits for the Hillary
Clinton campaign Philadelphia was a was
an area that she was counting on
Philadelphia and the surrounding suburbs
what were the deficits you know we're
looking at it right now we're really
paring into this map I think what's
really is surprising is that in some of
those Philadelphia what we call them
exurbs call them suburbs he did much
better there than expected you can look
at the map it's nearly all red we have
Philadelphia pick Spurs of course going
blue but it also thinks it really shouts
to and it's something that I think
really Barack Obama will be reflecting
on this evening is one thing that does
look true is that Hillary Clinton did
not generate the kind of enthusiasm
among the african-american community
that was needed she is pulling
percentage points behind there that will
have made a critical crucial difference
as we look at tightness not just in
around Philadelphia on Pittsburgh but it
was we look at tightness in Michigan
we're talking about Detroit they really
needed to come out with her she knew
needed that coalition we've talked
earlier tonight about how personal he
made this race how he put his own legacy
on the line she was not able tonight to
stitch together the coalition that
backed him in 2008 and 2012 whether that
was the wrong message whether that was
the wrong focus but it's all come home
to roost tonight you can't underestimate
the importance of this call this
projection by The Associated Press here
calling Pennsylvania for Donald Trump 20
electoral votes now moving into Donald
Trump's column stevia sino Bloomberg
politics give us the latest Megan Megan
said it there's just no path forward for
Hillary Clinton that's 20 electoral
votes from Pennsylvania gets Trump to
264 he's six away from 270 that's all he
would need and he still got Arizona 11
electoral votes in Arizona he's ahead
there by 4 points it's been about four
point lead all night that states not all
in yet we'll be watching it closely but
this is a state that's probably gonna go
to Donald Trump and he's so close in in
Wisconsin he's still close in New
Hampshire Pennsylvania this really just
wiped away Clinton's chances of reaching
the White House even I just want to
quickly go to that map and make sure
people can look at it all of us were
drawing our electoral maps many of us
who'd follow the campaign Meghan Green
has drawn her own electoral map I can
think of very very few people who would
have drawn a map with those kind of
states that we're seeing going red
that's right I mean we set up from the
very beginning we said that Donald Trump
needed to win it was an inside straight
right he had to get every Domino in this
race had to fall his way and the states
did starting you know down with the
Florida North Carolina Ohio actually was
first but then you get in Pennsylvania
nobody expected that and and we saw
early signs of it in Virginia when that
race was closed there was a signal that
this was going to be a longer night than
we expected and and it's redrawn the map
it really has a state that has been blue
since 1992 Meghan's so a huge change of
events here Bloomberg News
characterizing this in light of that
projection from The Associated Press
Donald Trump poised to become the
President of the United States of